she insists that um that diet and
exercise have almost nothing to do with
making you fat she made this case a
couple weeks ago to a visibly
incredulous journalist on 60 Minutes
listen to this if you diet you lose
weight the number one cause of obesity
is genetics that means if you are born
to parents that have obesity you have a
50 to 85 percent likelihood of having
the disease yourself so when people see
families that have obesity the
assumption is what are they feeding
those kids so she proposes that you
could have a near perfect diet you could
jog three miles a day you could never
touch fast food you could never touch
fried food you could eat no junk food
everything's great everything is fine
and you will still have up to an 85
percent likelihood of being obese
because your parents are you may do
everything right and still wake up one
morning like Tim Allen in the Santa
Claus suddenly morbidly obese with a
white beard and flying reindeer parked
in your front yard